Simplify the rational
expression
and state the domain.
Once again, we have a trinomial
over a trinomial.
To see if we can simplify
them, we need to
factor both of them.
That's also going to help us
figure out the domain.
The domain is essentially
figuring out all of the valid
x's that we can put into this
expression and not get
something that's undefined.
Let's factor the numerator
and the denominator.
So let's start with the
numerator there, and since we
have a 2 out front, factoring
by grouping will probably be
the best way to go, so let's
just rewrite it here.
I'm just working on the
numerator right now.
2x squared plus 13x plus 20.
We need to find two numbers,
a and b, that if I multiply
them, a times b, needs to be
equal to-- let me write it
over here on the right.
a times b needs to be equal to
2 times 20, so it has to be
equal to positive 40.
And then a plus b has
to be equal to 13.
The numbers that jump out
at me immediately
are 5 and 8, right?
5 times 8 is 40.
5 plus 8 is 13.
We can break this 13x into a
5x and an 8x, and so we can
rewrite this as 2x squared.
It'll break up the 13x into--
I'm going to write the 8x
first. I'm going to
write 8x plus 5x.
The reason why I wrote the 8x
first is because the 8 shares
common factors with the
2, so maybe we can
factor out a 2x here.
It'll simplify it
a little bit.
5 shares factors with the 20, so
let's see where this goes.
We finally have a plus
20 here, and now
we can group them.
That's the whole point of
factoring by grouping.
You group these first two
characters right here.
Let's factor out a 2x, so this
would become 2x times-- well,
2x squared divided by 2x
is just going to be x.
8x divided by 2x is going
to be plus 4.
Let's group these
two characters.
And if we factor out a
5, what do we get?
We get plus 5 times x plus 4.
5x divided by 5 is x, 20
divided by 5 is 4.
We have an x plus 4 in
both cases, so we
can factor that out.
We have x plus 4 times two
terms. We can undistribute it.
This thing over here will be x
plus four times-- let me do it
in that same color--
2x plus 5.
And we've factored
this numerator
expression right there.
Now, let's do the same thing
with the denominator
expression.
I'll do that in a different--
I don't want
to run out of colors.
So the denominator is right over
here, let's do the same
exercise with it.
We have 2x squared
plus 17x plus 30.
Let's look for an a and a b.
When I multiply them, I get
2 times 30, which is 60.
And an a plus a b, when
I add them, I get 17.
Once again, 5 and
12 seem to work.
So let's split this up.
Let's split this up
into 2x squared.
We're going to split up the 17x
into a 12x plus a 5x and
that adds up to 17x.
When you multiply 12 times 5,
you get 60, and then plus 30.
Then on this first group right
here, we can factor out a 2x,
so if you factor out a 2x, you
get 2x times x plus 6.
In that second group, we can
factor out a 5, so you get
plus 5 times x plus 6.
Now, we can factor out an x plus
6, and we get we get x
plus 6 times 2x plus 5.
We've now factored the numerator
and the denominator.
Let's rewrite both of these
expressions or write this
entire rational expression with
the numerator and the
denominator factored.
The numerator is going to
be equal to x plus 4
times 2x plus 5.
We figured that out
right there.
And then the denominator is
x plus 6 times 2x plus 5.
It might already jump out at you
that you have 2x plus 5 in
the numerator and the
denominator, and we
can cancel them out.
We will cancel them out.
But before we do that, let's
work on the second part of
this question.
State the domain.
What are the valid x values
that we could put in here?
A more interesting question is
what are the x values that
will make this rational
expression undefined?
It's the x values that will make
the denominator equal to
0, and when will the denominator
equal to 0?
Well, either when x plus 6 is
equal to 0, or when 2x plus 5
is equal to 0.
We could just solve
for x here.
Subtract 6 from both sides,
and you get x is equal to
negative 6.
If you subtract 5 from both
sides, you get 2x is equal to
negative 5.
Divide both sides by 2.
You get x is equal
to negative 5/2.
We could say the domain-- let
me write this over here.
The domain is all real numbers
other than or except x is
equal to negative 6 and x is
equal to negative 5/2.
The reason why we have to
exclude those is those would
make this denominator-- either
way you're right.
It's going to go make the
denominator equal to 0, and it
would make the entire rational
expression undefined.
We've stated the domain.
Now let's just simplify the
rational expression.
We've already said that x cannot
be equal to negative
5/2 or negative 6, so let's just
divide the numerator and
the denominator by 2x plus 5.
Or just looking at the 2x plus
5, we know that 2x plus 5
won't be 0, because x won't be
equal to negative 5/2, and so
we can cancel those out.
The simplified rational
expression is just x plus 4
over x plus 6.